let's dig into now the history of
whether tax cuts help the economy Donald
Trump's tax plan just released it's a
disaster as we've discussed he wants to
cut corporate taxes from thirty five to
fifteen percent cut individual tax rates
get rid of the alternative minimum tax
get rid of the estate tax so many other
things I recently talked about how if
you are a committed right winger and
you're confused about economics and you
think that tax cuts help the economy
then studies that show otherwise
probably won't change your mind but all
I can do is present you with the facts
so let's give it a shot okay as you can
see in this first image if you're
watching on YouTube or on free speech TV
or on our TV stations with us right now
in 1990 George HW Bush raised taxes and
GDP growth increased drastically over
the next five years in 1993 Bill Clinton
further raised the top marginal tax rate
and GDP growth again increased over the
next five years in 2001 George W Bush
cut taxes and we saw small rise small
dip small rise small dip in GDP growth
rates when George W Bush in 2003 cut tax
rates even more GDP growth tanked
plummeted to a low that we hadn't seen
in a long time GDP growth had almost
zero this was the beginning of the Great
Recession now this isn't evidence that
cutting taxes helps gdp growth or that
raising taxes hurts gdp growth but it
does allow us to deduce that tax cuts
don't in a sort of vacuum in a general
sense help economic growth and there are
of course many many factors in an
economy that impact gdp but what history
shows us and it follows basic logic is
that cutting taxes is not nearly a
surefire way of improving the economy
this was confirmed by one of the most
comprehensive studies that we've had on
whether tax cuts promote economic growth
a 65-year study was conducted by the
Congressional Research Service which is
a nonpartisan
in office published about five years ago
over 65 years the study found that top
tax rates are not associated with saving
investment or productivity growth and
the study found that cutting capital
gains taxes and top marginal tax rates
leads to more wealth in equality and
that's obvious why wouldn't that be the
case when rich people are given tax
breaks they mostly pocket the money
because they don't need the money the
money doesn't trickle down and get
spread through the economy in this way
that a lot of right-wingers supply
siders like to tell us in the 1950s when
the top marginal tax rate was above 90
percent both real GDP and real
per-capita GDP were growing twice as
fast as they are today when the top
marginal tax rate was 35 rather is 35
percent since 1945 the average tax rate
paid by the top tenth of one percent of
the wealthiest people has fallen from
fifty to twenty five percent and during
that time their share of income their
portion of all income earned in the
United States rose almost three times
from just over four percent to just over
twelve percent this means what when you
cut rich people's taxes not only do they
pay less in taxes they're able to start
earning much more and wealth inequality
gets even worse this next image shows
the tax rates of the top point one
percent and point oh one percent they
decreased drastically from 1945 to 2009
and compare that to this next image of
how their share of total income changed
hint it went up significantly by the way
this also debunks the right wing talking
point that taxes are higher than ever so
Donald Trump's proposed cuts will appeal
to supply siders it will maybe earn him
the point he needs with many Republicans
although not all I'll tell you about
that a little bit later certainly with
his friends and his financial backers
but keep in mind and I know that the
committed Trump is doesn't give a flying
you-know-what about
history tells us that cutting taxes
doesn't mean more income for Americans
in general it means that the rich will
get a bigger share of total income and
this is all happening while Donald Trump
continues to propose cutting crucial
government programs is this the worst
tax plan in decades send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
I'm coming to you today from the mass
torts made perfect conference in Las
Vegas Nevada much more after this